皆さんこんにちはどう件です
いくつかの報告がありまして動画を作ることにしました
とまず一つ目は8最近ヤフージャパンが8ユーユーチューブみたいにあの
みたいな動画を配信するサービスそー
作ったんですけれども僕もそのサービスを通して自分の動画をの塔子そのサービスに
自分の動画を投稿してるんですけれども
あの youtube ちょっとあの
異なった編集をしていてで何が違うかというと日本語の字幕をつけてるんで
まああの日本語を勉強している人達だったら
昔から僕のチャンネルにもん
日本語の字幕をつけてほしいとかってあの
結構いろんな人がいてたんだ言ってたんでもしあの
興味があれば良かったらあのー yahoo チャンネルも見てみ
見てみてください下記に輪行
載せておきますのではい
っていうのが一つ目です
一つ目ですで
二つ目はあのん
このいつもこのチャンネルにアップしている
a 今に道があるじゃないですかそれと全く別で音声学のレッスンを作ってるんですよ
ね
でまぁご存知の方が絵比較的に多いと思うんですけれども
赤でも
何だろう全くその話をしないのでまだ作ってるのかなぁとか
そのどんくらい
レッスンがあるのかなとかって思っている人がいるかなーと思って
まぁちょっとだけその話をさせていただきます
今のレッスンが56個ぐらいあるんです
でえまあ twitter のほうでは
定期的に何だろうそのレッスンのサンプルみたいな短い動画もアップしてるんです
けれども
youtube にも同じようなサンプルをこれからまあいくつか投稿したいなと思っ
ているんで
まあ
音声学のシーズがどんなものなのかっていうのが分かるように
アップしますよかったら見てみてください
ホットなんだったかな
[音楽]
はいえ
えっと
この前
もう一ヶ月ぐらい前になるちゃうんですけれども
長い動画も作ったじゃないですかなんか日本でマンションの購入
どういうどんな家庭なのかっていう動画まあ何本が何本
をつくったんですがう
a 似たような
比較的に長い英語での長い動画を
また作ろうと思ってるんでまあ次はどういうものかっていうと日本で働くこと
どういうものなのかっていう動画になります
なのでへまあ
質問をいただけたらなと今思っています
まあもし日本で働い
働いてみたいとか
日本の職場とアメリカの職場どう違うかとかまあそういった系の質問を頂けたらと
はいいただけると幸いです
パッドですねえええまあ今の自分の新しいオフィスで撮影をしているんですが
かなり今あの
緊張していますだから結構あの噛んだりとかしてるんですけれども
コーヒー飲み過ぎてなんかテンションがおかしいんですが
つかこのオフィスオフィスの話戻ります
ブーバーだいたいカーン急いだのでええまあもしアティ教えてください
もう僕も結構このマンション気に入っていて特にこのオフィスがー
まあいまぁ結構いいものなったんじゃないかなと思いますので
まあ
またつまらないアパートツアーみたいなものになっちゃうんですけれどもそういうもの
を見たいなっていう方がいれば教えてくださいはい
かなり長くなりました結構噛んだりとかしてて
幹部買うんだとかな com
はい com です
com じゃないですね
まあはい今のはまさにその音声楽のレッスンで教えていることです
っていうところ可能はいここで
終わりにしたいと思っています
以上です今後ともよろしくお願いします
tan
ni